a solitary Mass sits in empty space
very far out from it we release a ring
of neutral particles followed shortly
thereafter by another ring
and then another
if we repeat this process in a
continuous fashion we will soon have a
sea of particles flowing faster and
faster inwards towards the mass
what would you say this is a picture of
exactly
a large number of particles all subject
to an inwardly attractive Force
well what if it weren't these particles
which were moving at all but rather
space itself that was truly flowing
sweeping the particles other masses and
even light along with it
this is dialect with
the river model of general relativity
when is an analogy merely a tool for
comprehension and when is it something
more
indeed there's an analogy in general
relativity that asks us to imagine space
to be like a river
a sort of flowing background against
which all matter is swept into sinks of
mass and energy
at first glance this may not strike you
as a great analogy
how the heck can an abstract construct
like space flow into itself
what would such a statement even mean
but when we start to peel back the
layers to this analogy we'll find
there's something highly suggestive
going on
okay but first where does such an
analogy even come from
well start by imagining that you're on a
rocket ship blasting through outer space
next Imagine dropping a loose object off
of yourself
that object will fall to the floor
of course the object didn't really fall
the second You released it it stopped
accelerating and began traveling at a
constant velocity
while the rocket ship continued
accelerating up to meet it
foreign
now rather than a single object Imagine
You released a set of tiny particles in
the shape of a grid
in the same manner as before this grid
will also fall to the ground
this grid of course is a stand-in for
our traditional conception of space
so if we're accelerating we can make a
sort of funny sounding statement about
space
that is we can say space is Flowing past
us getting sucked into the rocket ship
floor as though that floor were a sink
or drain
loose objects floating on the current of
this space likewise get carried towards
the floor
and even a light beam itself will Arc
downwards as if with the current
of course if we weren't accelerating but
rather we're at rest or traveling at
constant velocity we wouldn't be able to
make such a statement because our space
grid would simply stay put
now if you're familiar with general
relativity at all you know there's
another kind of statement we can make
about being in an accelerating rocket
ship
we can claim that we perceive ourselves
to be in the presence of a homogeneous
gravitational field
this is the equivalence principle
by flipping it around we can also claim
that any frame in which we perceive a
gravitational field can likewise be
treated as accelerating
meaning we can make the same funny
assertion about being in a gravitational
field that we did about being in an
accelerating rocket ship
that is we can say that space itself is
Flowing past us
getting sucked no longer into the floor
but rather into the mass or source of
the field
now the primary place we perceive a
gravitational field is at the surface of
the Earth
okay but this is just a clever analogy
space isn't really flowing into the
Earth is it
well now comes the incredible fact that
you aren't actually at rest on the
surface of the Earth
the ground is in fact accelerating you
upwards at 9.8 meters per second squared
through space
if you drop an object off of yourself it
falls to the ground for the same reason
it did in the accelerating rocket ship
because the ground rushed up to meet it
if you're skeptical of this fact you can
prove it to yourself by stepping off of
a tall building
we said by stepping off of a tall
building
there we go
now this action will cause the
gravitational field in your immediate
vicinity to vanish before any light
signal has a chance to reach it
this is a violation of causality
for in a true force field such as the
electromagnetic one any disturbance to
the field can only propagate at the
speed of light
this fact in conjunction with an
empirical inability to measure the field
you are supposedly falling in forces you
to conclude that the field you perceived
the moment before you stepped off the
building was indeed a fictitious one
and that implies that it must be the
ground which is accelerating
not you
but this incredible fact immediately
raises a whole host of other questions
how can one part of the Earth's surface
be accelerating upwards while miles away
another part is also accelerating
upwards but in a slightly different
direction
and meanwhile at the untipital end of
the planet that same surface is somehow
accelerating in the completely opposite
direction
it becomes even more mind-boggling when
you realize that even though the Earth
is hurtling apart in every direction it
somehow remains stationary with respect
to itself even though there is no force
acting to pull it together
but this is where the idea that space is
Flowing becomes something more than just
an explanatory analogy
to answer the question of how we can all
be accelerating and yet all remain in
place it becomes useful to reinterpret
gravity not as a force that acts on
matter but rather as a force that acts
on Space itself causing it to rush and
flow in towards sinks of mass and energy
remaining stationary with respect to a
mass means different observers will have
to accelerate in different directions
and with different strengths in order to
overcome this flow or Rush
to make this clearer imagine that you
are motorboating
along a river
near a waterfall
the closer you get to the waterfall the
faster and faster the current begins to
rush
now if you want to stay stationary with
respect to the shore you'd have to fire
up your Motors and start accelerating
this acceleration wouldn't need to be
very great if you were far out from the
waterfall's edge but as you got closer
the increase in current will precipitate
a greater and greater acceleration of
your boat relative to the shore
meaning you are required to run your
Motors harder and harder in order to
stay put
indeed within a certain distance of the
waterfall's edge you may not be able to
accelerate hard enough to overcome the
current and you'll be swept over
meanwhile if you simply drifted along
with the current
you wouldn't feel any force on your boat
at all
even though you're clearly accelerating
relative to the shore
you would however feel a tidal pressure
stretching your boat apart since the
downstream end of your boat would be
getting pulled towards the waterfall
faster than the Upstream end
this tidal gradient also means that
other boats drifting along with you will
steadily see their distance with respect
to you increase over time
now instead of a linear River
let's imagine a large flat Basin of
water which is draining through a single
hole in the middle
in this setup boats will have to
accelerate
not only with different strengths but
also in different directions if they
want to remain stationary with respect
to the basin
boats that aren't accelerating but just
drifting with the current will now
experience tidal pressures not only in
the radial Direction but also in the
tangential direction as water rushing in
from all sides towards the drain will
act to squeeze the boat inwards
this will also cause boats that are
drifting along adjacent radial Avenues
to see their respective separations
steadily shrink over time
of course in this visual the Basin is
relatively small and drains fast so
these tidal effects will be very brief
and very strong
but a different picture might invoke a
very large very shallow body of water
draining through a comparatively small
Outlet something like a 360 degree river
which was headed towards a waterfall in
every direction
indeed in such a situation the supply of
water would be endless enough
and the accumulation of tidal forces
subtle enough that an observer
accelerating in place might not notice
the motion of the river at all and
rather think that objects floating on it
were being attracted inwards by a radial
force field that fell off with distance
now these pictures essentially sum up
how gravitation as modeled by flowing
space works
to see this let's start at the model of
the classic gravitational field where we
have vectors drawn in for the strength
and direction of the field at every
point
thanks to the equivalence principle we
can now take every one of these vectors
and flip it around to find the
respective strength and direction of
acceleration that an observer located
there would need to exert in order to
remain stationary with respect to the
Central Mass
from our earlier considerations we know
that this means for each tiny area in
the region we can say space is Flowing
past our Observer there
just as on the spaceship before we'll
let grids fall in these areas to give us
a general idea of how much speed the
current of space is picking up at each
location
now if we drop neutral particles from a
far distance the velocity of these
particles will be boosted as they cross
over from one tiny area to the next
this produces the so-called River of
space
which rushes faster and faster as it
nears the Central Mass
of course the true River of space is
three-dimensional
but for ease of both the visuals and the
analogy we're gonna stick to two
dimensions
now this River resembles our physical
rivers from earlier and indeed between
these various pictures we can observe
many similar phenomena
the downstream end of space rushing
ahead faster than the Upstream end for
instance gives rise to Tidal forces that
cause radially aligned inertial
observers to drift apart
similarly space rushing in from all
sides causes those same observers if
they occupy different radio Avenues to
drift closer together
for something such as a grid of neutral
particles the total tidal deformation
produced upon it by the flow of space
will be the same as the deformation
produced upon a grid of say rubber
duckies by the flow of our 360 degree
River
but the most powerful aspect of the
river picture is furnished by the simple
intuition that any matter within this
River will be subject to its movement
and Flow
just as how objects cut on the current
of an actual River are subject to its
flow
this idea applies to even light itself
yes light always travels through space
in a straight line at 300 000 kilometers
per second
but as we saw earlier on the rocket ship
that space can itself be in motion and
indeed close enough to a spherical Mass
the converging flow of the river
indicates space is likewise converging
in every direction
resulting in the deflection or bending
of the trajectory of that light beam as
it passes by
now by the time the river of space
reaches us at the surface of the Earth
it will have obtained to a velocity of
approximately 11 000 meters per second
In classical physics this value is known
as our planet's escape velocity
but in the river model it's the velocity
at which you are traveling through space
indeed your continual acceleration of
9.8 meters per second squared at the
surface of the Earth ensures that you
are always traveling through the river
of space at this velocity
similar to how accelerating in place in
a river ensures that you are always
traveling the same speed over the water
now at last we can understand how the
Earth can be accelerating outwards in
every direction at once and yet remain
stationary
every point of its surface is merely
fighting against a different inflow of
space
this also explains why the earth's
surface is accelerating in the first
place if we imagine a bunch of boats in
our Basin all getting stuck together
atop the drainage point they will be
forced to accelerate over the in-rushing
water due to their Mutual blockage
likewise we can view the mass of the
earth as being all jammed up over the
inflow point of space forcing a radially
outwards acceleration across all parts
of the mass
lastly just as there comes a point in
our physical River where the current
becomes so strong we won't be able to
run our Motors hard enough to overcome
it
there comes a point where the current of
space becomes so overpowering that no
amount of acceleration will negate it
this is the Event Horizon of a black
hole
or the place where the river of space
reaches the speed of light
two observers outside this Horizon here
at this location the inward Rush of
space exactly matches the outward
movement of light making it appear as
though that light itself were frozen in
place and that time had ground to a halt
in Falling observers meanwhile are
transported to a realm where space is
now traveling possibly faster than the
speed of light
technically if we don't want to think of
space as having a single preferred speed
we should rather say that at the Event
Horizon of a black hole observers are
being boosted by an amount equal to the
speed of light
of course thanks to the special additive
properties of velocities in special
relativity any velocity that is boosted
by the speed of light simply becomes
equal to the speed of light
so indeed at the Event Horizon of a
black hole all and every possible
conception of space is traveling there
at the speed of light
this is indeed like approaching a
massive current gradient in a river a
place where over a very short distance
the speed of the water and all objects
on it will increase drastically
in other words a black hole is to space
what a waterfall is to a river
how far can an analogy take us
obviously the comparison of space to a
physical River breaks down at numerous
points and is only intended to be
illustrative
but the concept of flowing space on the
other hand can be made formally precise
via the use of the gold strand pun Levy
metric
moreover it can be extended to other
metrics to help us describe rotating
black holes and more
but is all this just an illustrative way
of interpreting space-time curvature or
is there a deeper underlying connection
indeed how is all this supposed to
relate to the warping of space and time
well our journey down this particular
River has only just begun
so climb aboard now because boy
Revelations are coming
this has been dialect thanks for
watching
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]